just before we get started i will say
that this video is sponsored by quincy
400.
for most presidents their long-term
reputation lives and dies upon what they
did during their administration herbert
for example was a great humanitarian now
only remembered for a much greater
depression no one meanwhile seriously
remembers woodrow wilson for overhauling
princeton university heck even dwight d
eisenhower is better known for his two
terms than winning goddamn world war ii
but occasionally you get a president
whose deeds before or after their
administration are central to their
place in history of these perhaps none
is so fascinating as john quincy adams
the sixth president of the united states
adams was also the white house's first
major disappointment in a single term he
failed to do anything much of
consequence existing mainly as a human
punching bag for his successor andrew
jackson yet rather than the pinnacle the
presidency would turn out to be a brief
dip in his otherwise remarkable life as
secretary of state pre-presidency adams
helped shape america in profound ways in
his post-white house career he became
one of the most powerful anti-slavery
voices in the nation a mediocre
ineffectual president who still
transforms the united states this is the
life of john quincy adams america's
greatest failure
when john quincy adams was born in
braintree massachusetts later named
quincy on july the 11th 1767 it was into
a seemingly average family his parents
weren't incredibly rich or highly
connected and while his father was
fiercely interested in politics he
wasn't exactly a mover and shaker but of
course we already know there was nothing
average about adams family his dad was
future founding father john adams his
mum future first lady abigail adams and
that ensured there would be nothing
remotely average about john quincy's
upbringing things got moving in 1774
with the calling of the first
continental congress essentially a big
convention dedicated to discussing what
a [ __ ] george iii was adams's dad
was one of their state's delegates but
while this was the family's first
flirtation with history it would be what
came next that really transformed their
fortunes on april 19th 1775 some
forgotten soldier at lexington fired
their gun during a tense standoff
between british forces and american
militia it was the opening of the
american revolutionary war the shot
heard around the world it was also the
starting gun on john adams's high
velocity career with his dad running off
to join the second continental congress
that spring john quincy always left to
witness the war unfold from his mother's
side like literally that summer abigail
took her son to the top of a nearby hill
from where they could see the distant
carnage of the battle of bunker hill the
next few years the boy would frequently
see soldiers marching through his
hometown then there were the fears he
felt for his dad on july the 4th 1776
john adams signed his name on the
declaration of independence one hour
celebrated moment it was at the time
treason and adams was paralyzed by the
fear that the british might execute his
dad not that there was much space for
airing these fears at home always a hard
woman abigail adams had transformed by
the war into a mother determined to
raise a future american leader she would
truck no emotions from her boy no
idleness nothing at all that most of us
would associate with childhood and that
meant that john quincy grew up faster
than even other kids in this turbulent
era aged just 10 he was sent with his
dad on a dangerous diplomatic trip to
europe on which saw british ships stalk
and harass their vessel on a second
voyage the following year the boat
sprang a leak barely making it to the
spanish coast getting to paris then
required a grueling two-month trek on
mules at this time john quincy was also
taking on diplomatic responsibilities
like teaching the french minister to the
united states english or sitting in on
meetings between his dad and benjamin
franklin it was as if john and abigail
were trying to fashion their son into a
machine for diplomacy a sort of nerdy
robocop built for geopolitics as abigail
wrote to her still prepubescent son
these are the times in which a genius
would wish to live it is not in the
still calm of life or the repose of a
pacific station that great characters
are formed which was maybe why adam's
life in europe was as far from still
as it's possible to get over the years
of the war john quincy lived in holland
and france spending time in sweden and
prussia he became fluent in french
passable and dutch age 14 he was
appointed secretary and translator to
the u.s embassy to russia in time he'd
master seven languages but his biggest
moment came at the age of 16. in 1783
adams served as a secretary to the
american delegation in paris watching
from up close as a peace treaty was
thrashed out with britain ending the
revolutionary war it was an invaluable
insight into international politics what
adams would take into his future
diplomatic ventures but first the
teenage john quincy wanted to return to
america
[Music]
as he reached adulthood john quincy
adams had grown into a highly
intelligent well-traveled and well-read
young man he also however had grown into
a neurotic mess an ill-tempered
emotionally cold egotist who most people
instinctively disliked in short the
ideal combination for professional
success and personal misery first the
professional success back in the us john
quincy graduated harvard passed the bar
and began practicing law all by the age
of 23. he also found a side gig writing
articles in support of the new
president's articles that soon brought
him to george washington's attention it
probably didn't hurt that washington's
vice president was john quincy's dad in
1794 the president appointed him
minister to the netherlands and adams
returned to europe okay so that's the
amazing career what about the personal
misery for that we need to look no
further than adams's love life while in
the u.s john quincy had fallen
spectacularly for a local girl he'd even
wanted to propose but then abigail had
told him that he needed to focus on his
career so adams broke off with the young
woman only to regret the decision
immediately and intensely in fact he
regretted it so much that when he met 22
year old louisa catherine in london he
didn't even hesitate before asking her
to marry him the daughter of an american
expat and an english woman louisa was
intelligent creative exactly the sort of
things that most people would want in a
fiance the problem was adams wasn't most
people he actively refused to be in the
same room as louisa when she played
music and could barely stand talking to
her they married in july 1797. by the
time louise became the first of only two
foreign-born first ladies the pair could
go literal weeks without speaking but
that was still many years away for now
the young adams simply kept up his
diplomatic work becoming his dad's man
in prussia after john adams gained the
presidency then returning to america
again when his dad lost it not that this
loss impacted adams own career elected
to the massachusetts state senate in
1802 adams was quickly promoted to one
of the state's two congressional
senators massachusetts c was controlled
by the federalist party since his dad
had been a federalist the leadership
assumed adams was as safe about as they
could make but that assumption couldn't
have been more wrong in congress john
quincy surprised everyone by frequently
siding not with his dad's federalists
but with their opponents the democratic
republicans this included weighty stuff
like the 1807 embargo act which blocked
trade with all foreign nations a brave
attempt to get britain to respect
america's maritime rights but one with
the unfortunate side effect of screwing
over adams's home base of new england
yet adams voted for the measure feeling
his conscience would not allow him to do
otherwise in massachusetts though the
federalists felt that adams
consciousness could kiss their butts
outraged at his betrayal they announced
his replacement before his term was even
over five days later adams resigned
shortly after he was spotted at the
democratic republican convention his
switch to the enemy party
now official but while this mountain
made him as popular with federalists as
a carolina reaper enema it was also an
excellent career move in the 1808
election democratic republican james
madison trounced his federalist rival he
awarded john quincy switch of allegiance
with the job of u.s minister to russia
and so it was back to europe back to a
continent broken and bruised by the
napoleonic wars from his vantage point
in saint petersburg adams was able to
witness france's failed invasion of
russia to take part in the negotiations
with britain that ended the war of 1812
to watch napoleon's collapse at waterloo
come 1817 john quincy was living in
london with more experiences under his
belt the most managed in a lifetime yet
it would be the next seven years that
saw his greatest achievements of all
back home james monroe had just been
elected president and he had the perfect
role lined up for the worldly
intelligent john quincy adams he wanted
adams to become his secretary of state
[Music]
although on paper he was the perfect
candidate deep down adams was worried
worried that monroe had made the wrong
choice worried that he'd be a failure as
he wrote to abigail he felt that the
president had overestimated not the
goodness of my intentions but the extent
of my talents for a man so egotistical
he once called his own diaries the most
precious and valuable book ever written
by human hands such fears seem
remarkable an indication that adams
really did sense he might not be fit for
high office and while time and the
highest office in the land would
eventually prove him right in 1817 the
opposite happened john quincy adams was
about to become perhaps the best
secretary of state the u.s ever had
adams is genius in his ability to
negotiate under his watch vital treaties
were signed that changed america forever
the most vital of these the treaties
with britain and spain at this point
remember adams had lived through two
major wars with britain and voted for
legislation designed to cuddle trade
ties with london so he'd have been
forgiven for making his official stance
screw
those limey douchebags but no instead
adams spearheaded the convention of 1818
which permanently set the u.s canadian
border along the 49th parallel all the
way to the rocky mountains with a ban on
armaments along the border this treaty
helped diffuse 50 years of tensions
between london and washington ushering
in a new era in which redcoats weren't
constantly trying to burn down the white
house more important still though may
have been the treaty with spain signed
in 1819 the treaty saw florida
officially handed to the united states
and spain give up its claims to
territory north of latitude 42 degrees
since this included oregon county it set
the stage for yet further u.s expansion
westward in the future in return the
southern border was set with madrid's
colony of new spain giving the spaniards
control of texas but since spain was
about to get booted out of what is now
mexico uncle sam wouldn't have to worry
about keeping up his end of the bargain
for very long impressive as these
treaties were though perhaps adams's
biggest achievement was a speech which
doesn't even bear his name the monroe
doctrine takes its name from the
president who first articulated it but
the idea was nearly all john quincy
adams's in a nutshell the doctrine told
europe to forget sailing across the
atlantic to do more colonizing the newly
independent american nations would stay
independent and any attempt to say
otherwise would result in a
star-spangled foot being inserted up the
old continent's backside at the time
this was a ballsy statement like scrappy
doo threatening to go 10 rounds with
cujo the u.s simply wasn't powerful
enough to be bossing multiple empires
around but it was also a sign of how the
tides were shifting of how the western
hemisphere was turning towards the u.s
in decades to come the monroe doctrine
would be used to justify all sorts of
unwelcome intrusions in latin america
but it's no doubt its unveiling was a
pivotal moment so that was john quincy's
career as his time as secretary of state
drew to a close while with the track
record of three major wins plus a minor
victory professionalizing the diplomatic
service stacked together all this made
adams feel like it got a pretty good
shot at taking over from monroe when the
president left office the trouble was he
wasn't the only one as the election year
of 1824 dawned it was on a country that
had dramatically changed the federalist
party heard collapsed male suffrage had
been expanded 18 of the 24 states now
chose their presidential electors by
popular vote it would in short be a
watershed election one that would
fulfill john quincy's wildest dreams
even as it laid the groundwork for his
political destruction
[Music]
although only one party contested the
1824 election that doesn't mean there
was only one candidate alongside adams
three other men all vied for the top job
each with their own bases of power it
was the fire brand house speaker henry
clay of kendaki the favorite of the
elites william h crawford but it was the
outsider candidate that would throw all
of adams's hopes into disarray the
popular and populist tennessee general
andrew jackson from the get-go the race
was messy divided and as bitter as
cyanide that summer crawford was put
forward under the old caucus system
selected not by voters but by
congressmen leaning on crawford's
selection as undemocratic massachusetts
legislature instead nominated adams down
in kentucky the same thing happened with
henry clay but it was andrew jackson who
put up the most vigorous opposition
putting on rallies that made the pro
adams faction's efforts look like the
class nerd's unattended birthday parties
because the class nerd is kind of what
adams was he was clever yes even
brilliant but he was also widely
disliked the martin prince of
presidential politics there was no way
in this era when the popular vote
actually mattered that cerebral adams
could win against a natural populist
like jackson when the results came it
was clear john quincy's presidential bid
had failed while it left client crawford
eating his dust taking 30.9 percent of
the popular vote adams had only won new
england and new york jackson meanwhile
had captured 11 states and 41.4 percent
of the vote and you don't need to be a
john quincy style genius to know that 41
was a much higher number than 31. so
this is it then the moment when we
reveal that all of this has just been an
incredibly long intro to our andrew
jackson biography well not exactly see
jackson may have taken the most votes
and states but his delicate count at the
electoral college was 99 to 32 short of
a majority that meant the 12th amendment
kicking in meaning the house would now
decide the outcome on a one-state
one-vote basis and with clay prevented
from moving to the second round that
meant vital delegates were still in play
on february 9 1825 the house held its
contingent election disgusted by jackson
clay convinced all of his states to back
adams he and former federalists then
began pressuring others to back the
sensible john quincy over the fiery
andrew jackson incredibly the campaign
worked on the first ballot 13 states
threw their support to adams giving him
the simple majority needed to be
declared winner john quincy adams would
now become the sixth president of the
united states to call jackson outraged
would be to underestimate how
volcanically his rage erupted on hearing
the results the general accused adams
and clay of conspiring to make a corrupt
bargain a charge adam seemed to confirm
when he appointed clay his secretary of
state while historians today don't think
that any shady bargain existed the
optics were still terrible for anyone
even remotely pro-jackson it appeared
the election had been stolen even adam
seemed to recognize this acknowledging
to the american people i am less
possessed of your confidence in advance
than any of my predecessors yet
ultimately it wouldn't matter as he
assumed the presidency john quincy adams
did so with a bold plan for the future
one that would be so transformative so
beneficial that andrew jackson would
soon be forgotten
yeah
about that as adams was about to
discover being president is not the same
as being an old timey king you need
support in both chambers broad following
among the public the sixth president had
none of these things and now adams was
going to find out just how hard ruling
as a lame duck really is
there can be few u.s presidents with
such a stark gap between what they
intended to achieve and what they
actually managed to do when john quincy
adams entered the white house it was
with an ambitious program designed to
wed the states into a true nation with a
vast internal market and a strong
executive adams wanted to construct
roads and canals to connect americans to
standardize weights and measures to
build universities and observer trees
and dispatch survey teams to map
everything the continent had to offer
yet while he would see modest success
with construction projects including the
lake erie canal mostly what adams would
see would be endless failure 1820s
america didn't see an early new deal in
his plans for massive public works no
what they saw were attempts to drain
power from states and pump it directly
to washington more to the point they
also saw a president elected in a
contentious manner suddenly acting like
he was the messiah of government reform
but rather than the messiah congress
would treat adams as a very naughty boy
from the get-go the sixth president was
hampered in all his goals spurned even
by former supporters for two years
things just about held together but then
1826 rolled around and adam's world fell
apart first his father always his
staunchest supporter died from a heart
attack with his dad gone adams lost the
one person he could truly count on yet
his personal isolation would soon be
compounded by a second disaster in the
midterm elections that year jacksonians
took control of congress determined to
block everything adams tried to do in
the two years since the contingent
election jackson hadn't remotely
mellowed instead launching an endless
campaign against the president all while
building an election-winning machine
with congress now solidly against him
adams would spend the rest of his
presidency unable to do anything but
helplessly watch as his ambitions
crumbled to dust there were the
delegates adams wanted to send to panama
for a meeting of american nations only
for congress to block their funding or
the tariff package congress forced him
to authorize that was so unpopular it
became known as the tariff of
abominations even when adams tried to do
rights such as supporting the rights of
creek indians to have their territory
respected congress still rejected him
now this doesn't mean adams was an
actively bad president stacked next to
him james buchanan it looks positively
great but it does mean that he became a
mediocre president one whose term would
be defined by inertia
drift and ever shrinking expectations
against this backdrop the 1828 election
was almost a mercy killing now at the
head of the newly formed democratic
party andrew jackson was back and he was
ready for vengeance that winter the
general won a crushing victory taking
55.5 percent of the vote and dominating
the electoral college like his father
before him john quincy was now
officially a one-term president and just
like his father before him adam's left
under a grumpy cloud refusing to attend
his successors inauguration but while
this would be the end of most
presidential bios barring a quick
paragraph explaining how they died
adams's biography still has a final
chapter because after a disappointing
presidency
his career was going to have one last
glorious high in the coming years john
quincy adams was going to reinvent
himself as nothing less than the
conscious of his nation
in the 1840s there was nothing
guaranteed to silence the house faster
than old man eloquent standing up to
speak as the 70-something john quincy
adams rose a hush would descend
representatives from the democrats and
whigs alike would wait in respectful
quiet to see what their elder had to say
but this respect wasn't just due to
adams age or the fact that he'd once
been president rather it was due to his
long and extraordinary post-white house
career after he lost the election john
quincy had gone into retirement moping
miserably around massachusetts as the
jacksonian revolution got underway but
then some neighbors had pressured him to
run for congress and adams had won
entering the house in december of 1831.
at the time many thought it beneath him
a former president reduced to just one
of hundreds of representatives as adams
put it though no person could be
degraded by serving the people and serve
was exactly what adams intended to do
over 16 plus years john quincy would
forge a second career speaking out
forcefully against aggressive expansion
against the war with mexico but his
greatest most lasting achievement would
be his opposition to slavery of the
first 12 presidents the only ones who
didn't own enslaved people were john
quincy and his dad and while john quincy
would never publicly declare himself an
abolitionist his actions in the house
sure suggest that he was leaning that
way his biggest battle was against the
gag rule which banned debate on any
petition concerning slavery convinced
this was an insult to the first
amendment adams launched what can only
be described as a crusade against it
from 1836 he violated the rule whenever
he could attempting to get anti-slavery
petitions read into record risking the
wrath of southerners for years it looked
like a fool's errand but you know that
old quote often misattributed to gandhi
first they ignore you then they laugh at
you then you win well adams kept going
until he won in 1844 the house relented
voting to end the gag rule by then adams
was already fighting slavery on other
fronts in 1841 he'd gone before the
supreme court to argue the amistad case
on behalf of slaves who'd mutineed
aboard a spanish ship only to be
captured by american sailors adams
argument was a blistering denunciation
of slavery is against american founding
principles saying the moment you come to
the declaration of independence that
every man has a right to life and
liberty an inalienable right this case
is decided i ask nothing more in behalf
of these unfortunate men than this
declaration he won the case and the
former slaves went free yet while john
quincy would spend his latter years
chipping away at the edifice of slavery
he sadly wouldn't live to see the whole
rotten system collapse on february 21
1848 adams had just finished making a
passionate speech in the house when he
suffered a massive stroke carried to a
sofa in the speaker's office he died two
days later his last words were this is
the end of earth but i am content john
quincy adams passed away at the age of
80 leaving behind a career so long and
complex that even now it's impossible to
neatly summarize on the one hand his
time as president was a disappointment a
single term in which little was
accomplished on the other though his
careers both pre and post-presidency
were seemingly sprinkled with gold dust
charmed things that glittered brightly
next to the dreary grave is one term
it's fascinating isn't it how
ill-equipped we often are to deal with a
narrative that subverts our expectations
that doesn't climax with the presidency
but with the roles of secretary of state
and representative roles we assume are
somehow lesser but the life of the sixth
president shows us this isn't the case
the presidential rankings can never
capture all the good and bad of a
person's life in summing up john quincy
adams then perhaps we should instead
look to the words of his wife louisa who
once described him as exasperating
tendentious self-absorbed and yet in the
end
magnificent
i hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]